we're slowly transitioning a little bit
in tomorrow crypto and the first talk is
going to be bad hear me laugh at it
thank you my topic is on classical
verification of quantum computation this
topic lies in cryptography complexity
theory and quantum computing so I'll try
to keep it at a high enough level so
that most of you can follow but I
encourage you to ask a lot of questions
during the talk so I'll start by telling
you what the question is so the way to
imagine it is you have an
experimentalist who has access to a
quantum computer and we think of the
experimentalist as a classical being and
her goal is to verify that the quantum
computer is behaving correctly in the
sense that the quantum computers
behavior is consistent with our
theoretical model of how quantum
computer should behave so what she does
is she asked the quantum computer to
perform a specific quantum circuit and
we'll assume that the output to this
quantum circuit is a single bit it's
either 0 or 1 so the quantum circuit
will return that single bit and the
experimentalists goal is to verify that
this bit is correct so that the quantum
computer perform the correct quantum
computation and now I think many people
have heard of this question before and
you know why it's important so I'm not
going to spend much time motivating why
this is important but instead I'll just
tell you how it's been studied in our
community so in our community we've
looked at it through the lens of
interactive proofs and here we replace
the classical experimental ists with a
verifier and the quantum computer is
referred to as approver and now the
verifier is going to interact
classically with the prover over some
number of rounds and her goal is to use
this added power of classical
interaction in order to verify the
behavior of the quantum computer so this
question was first stated by Daniel
goddess Minh in 2004 and since then it's
been extensively studied and again I'm
not gonna cover the previous work here
with a goal of leading some extra time
for more technical content but instead
I'll go directly into the setting in
which I'm going to talk about it here
and that's with post quantum
cryptography so in this talk I'm gonna
focus on how we can address this
question of classical verification of
computations using post quantum crypto
so the key difficulty in this setting is
that the classical verifier is much
weaker than the quantum prover there's a
huge power imbalance here and that's
where a post quantum crypto can be
really helpful because what we can do is
we can used post quantum crypto to
upper-bound the power of the quantum
machine so we can take advantage of the
fact that the quantum machine quantum
machine is polynomial time bounded and
we can use some crypto that even the
quantum machine cannot break so this is
referred to so I'm just using classical
cryptography that an efficient quantum
computer cannot break for example one of
the most commonly used candidate
itslearning with errors which was
introduced by a dead rat goes in 2005 so
so far all i've said is that there's a
power imbalance between the classical
verifier and the quantum hoover and we
can address the power imbalance by upper
bounding the power of the quant
improvement unfortunately this isn't
enough because the classical verifier is
still much weaker than the quant
improver so to address the remaining
imbalance we can allow the classical
machine access to a trapdoor which can
restore the balance in some sense so by
giving the classical machine access to a
trapdoor
maybe the verifier can compute something
that even the quantum proved it cannot
and this added power turns out to be
enough to allow the verifier to verify
quantum computations and now just to
give you a brief example of how this
might work imagine a setting in which we
could use cryptography to allow the
prover to create the following state so
this is just a uniform superposition
with a phase of either 1 or negative 1
and the phase is dependent on this bit R
and what we'd like is that the bit R can
be computed by the verify our using the
trapdoor but is computationally
difficult for the prover to compute so
this is just a very rough example of how
cryptography might help us and in the
rest of the talk I'll tell you how we
can actually build crypto that would
allow us to do something like this and
then extend it to verification and the
key point here is that the prover is
holding a quantum state which is unknown
to him because it's hard for him to
compute that bit R but is known to the
verifier because
verify can efficiently compute the bit
are using the trapdoor so now let me get
into the cryptography that we'll need to
do this and so this cryptographic
primitive is called a trapdoor claw free
function pair and I'll first define it
and show how it can be used as a test
for quantum as' and then I'll show how
it can be used to verify quantum
computations okay so this primitive was
introduced by Goldwater Macaulay under
vest in 84 and it's a pair of functions
F 0 and F 1 which are injective and they
have the same image and the there's a
property which is called the claw free
property which says that for both
quantum and classical machines it's hard
to find a cloth which is a pair of pre
images x0 and x1 which map to the same
image and finally there's a trapdoor
which allows for efficient inversion so
given the trapdoor and an image Y
there's an algorithm which can output x0
and x1 which are the two pre images of
what so what these two points are saying
is without the trapdoor it's hard for
both quantum and classical machines to
find two pre images which map to the
same point but with the trapdoor there's
an algorithm that can take as input any
image and output the two pre images
which correspond to that image ok now
quantum computers can do something
pretty interesting here what a quantum
machine can do is sample a random image
Y and create a uniform superposition
over the corresponding clock and I'll
tell you how this is done in a second
but for now let me just tell you why
this is interesting why it sets quantum
machines apart from classical machines
and when you first look at this
superposition it might seem a little
strange because I said earlier that it's
hard for a quantum machine to find a
clock to find x0 and x1 but the
superposition seems to contain
information about both free images so to
see why that's not a contradiction the
first thing to note is that this state
has to be measured to gain information
and so let's see what happens if we
measure in two different basis if we
measure in the standard basis we'll
obtain either
one of the two pre images with equal
probability that's not particularly
interesting because that can easily be
reproduced by a classical probability
distribution now if we measure this in
the Hadamard basis then we'll obtain a
string d which satisfies this equation
so this is the part that seems
interesting because the string D
satisfies this equation which has to do
with both members of the cloth both x0
and x1 even though the quantum machine
itself can't find the clock so this is
something that we believe to be a
uniquely quantum capability and the way
to formalize that is to see what would
happen if this was possible classically
and it turns out we can rule this out
because if this were possible
classically it would mean that the
classical machine could essentially hold
both one of the two pre images x0 x1 and
a single bit of the other and this is a
stronger property than the claw free
property it's called we called the
adaptive hardcore bit property and it
says that it's hard to hold both a
pre-image and a single bit of the other
pre image and if we can prove this then
we're kind of ruling out this capability
of sampling the string D for classical
machines so we have a TCF implementation
from learning with errors this within
joint work with Becca Bukowski Paul
Christiana and for that implementation
we showed that this adaptive hardcore
bit property which is the strengthening
of the claw free property holds ok so
now that I showed you that a quantum
machine can obtain the string D the next
thing I'll do is I'll formalize this so
I said a quantum machine can do this a
classical machine can't so this forms a
test for quantumness and I'll formalize
what it means to test for quantumness
and I'll show you how this primitive can
be used to test for others before that
let me just fill in a detail that I
skipped over which is how the
superposition can be created okay so we
want a quantum machine to create the
superposition and what the quantum
machine does is he first creates a
uniform superposition over the bit B and
the string X which is the domain of the
function
he applies either F 0 or F 1 depending
on that first bit beat and now he
measures that last register to obtain an
image where and at this point due to the
entanglement in the state the state
collapses to that state on the first one
there are two pre images of Y X 0 and X
1 so the state collapses and this is a
pretty easy thing for a quantum machine
to do so this is how the quantum machine
samples a random image Y along with a
superposition over the clock okay so now
I can go into the test for quantumness
but before that are there any questions
about the TCF so far ok so the test for
quantum is it's a test between a
classical machine and another machine
that's claiming to be fun and the
guarantee for this test should be that
if the Machine passes either it's a
classical machine which takes an
exponential long time or it's a quantum
machine and if we can build such a test
and it would serve as a protocol for
verifiable quantum supremacy it's
proving that a machine is quantum and
it's also efficiently classically
now I can build this test for
quantumness using a TCF pair and here's
how it goes
the verifier first selects a TCF pair F
0 F 1 he hangs on to the trapdoor and
sends over the public description of the
function to the river the river responds
with an image Y which an honest machine
should do by sampling a random image Y
while creating a uniform superposition
over what's the verifier receives Y so
there if I ask for either a pre image Y
or a string D which satisfies this
equation
the verifier can then check if the pre
rup asses by using the chapter so the
verifier can use the trapdoor to look at
y extract x0 and x1 and then check that
the string d satisfies that equation now
from what I've told you so far it's very
easy for a quantum machine to pass the
test because the quantum machine can
create this uniform superposition and
then if the verify asks for a pre-image
he can measure the state in the standard
basin verify I asked for a string d he
can measure the state in Hat Amuro basis
but the point of this was to separate
quantum from classical so we know it's
easy for quantum but why is it hard for
classical now what would happen is if a
classical machine could pass the test we
could rewind the class of a classical
machine and run him on both a pre-image
test and an equation test and if you do
that then he'll hold both either x0 or
x1 and the string D which satisfies this
equation which means he's learning a
single bit of the other preimage and
therefore violating the adaptive
hardcore bit so what this says is that
it's computationally difficult for a
classical machine to pass a test if he
passes the test he's breaking learning
with her but a quantum for a quantum
machine it's very easy and why is that
it's essentially because we can't use
the same proof strategy for quantum
machines quantum machines cannot be
rewound once the quantum machine passes
the preimage test he's collapsed his
state and now he can't use the same
state to pass the to produce a string
deep
now this protocol has several
implications but first of what I
mentioned earlier if a machine can
perform both tasks
it cannot be classical which gives a
protocol for verifiable quantum
supremacy in is that if a machine can
perform both tasks
it cannot be deterministic because if it
were a deterministic machine we could
extract both a pre-image and an equation
out of it and again violate the adaptive
hardcore bit so this gives us a protocol
for certified randomness generation
because we know that if a machine is
passing both of these tests he's
generating randomness this structure
this TCF structure is also very useful
for homomorphic encryption and the
homework that encryption I'm referring
to is using classical homomorphic
encryption schemes to evaluate quantum
circuits you said it can't be
deterministic well if it's not
deterministic then he must be producing
randomness you can certify whether the
machine is passing these tests or not
so yeah what you have to prove is that
you're generating work and it does take
some work I mean yeah it takes it takes
a lot of work what kinds of things you
you have to make sure that you're
putting in less random
what's the ratio for how much we're
putting into how much we're getting out
I am just wondering how how small it
might be it is going to be larger than a
constant or not
okay so yeah this doctor is also useful
for homomorphic encryption I'll say a
little bit more about that later but not
too much and the final thing that this
is useful for is this classical
verification of quantum computation so
so far what I've shown you is that we
can use cryptography to create a task
which separates quantum and classical
machines the next thing I'll show you is
how the same cryptography the same TCF
pair can be used to force classical
commitment to quantum states well define
what that means and then I'll show you
how to CF pairs can be used for that but
before that let me just briefly tell you
how t CF pairs are constructed from
learning with errors and if this is
unfamiliar to you you can ignore the
next two slides and I won't get back to
learning with errors after that okay so
for the TCF construction from learning
with areas.the an lwe instance defines a
TCF pair f0 and f1 and here's what the
TCF pair looks like f0 is approximately
just it's the matrix a multiplied by the
input an f1 it's almost the same thing
but it's shifted by the LW example and I
say approximately because both of these
functions will be probabilistic
functions so both of them will be this
lattice point perturbed by some error
and that's what makes them overlap so as
long as we set the air appropriately the
images of these two functions will be
statistically close and the trapdoor is
easy it's just the lattice trap door of
a the clock free property is also pretty
straightforward because what the claws
look like a claw x0 and x1 has a form
that x1 equals x0 minus s so finding a
claw x0 and x1 implies finding the lwe
secret and breaking the lwe breaking
although me and the adaptive hardcore
bit is a bit trickier what it says is
that for all nonzero strings it should
be hard to guess that bit the inner
product of D and s
and for people in crypto this might seem
straightforward because there are
various techniques and photography like
leakage resilience for learning with
errors which address this question
unfortunately it is a bit more difficult
because the string D is chosen
adaptively so the string D is chosen
after the function a a s plus B is given
and that makes it trickier and we can't
just use leakage resilience techniques
ok so that's also all I'll say about
this function but one more side note is
earlier I said that this structure is
also used for homomorphic encryption so
it's used for using classical
homomorphic encryption schemes to
evaluate quantum circuits and what I
meant there was that if a home if a
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
has a TCF structure in the sense that I
just showed that lwe has a TCF structure
then this classical homomorphic
encryption scheme can be immediately
used to evaluate quantum circuits and
luckily there are quite a few quan
classical homomorphic encryption schemes
which are essentially exactly lwe so we
can directly use these schemes to
evaluate quantum circuits all marketly
okay so this is all I'm gonna say about
learning with errors and we're in the
cryptography and now I'm going to go
back to this classical commitment yeah
maybe a simplistic question
you used ships and I guess she's
propagator I guess you that's because
you wanted to use it could you also
infused learning parody with noise
instead of actually learning parody with
noise it's really interesting because if
we can get learning parody with noise to
work meaning if we can build a TCF out
of it then it seems like we can get
quantum computers to break learning
parity whose noise which means that it
shouldn't work we shouldn't be able to
set the parameters of learning parody
with noise to build TCF
because okay so what happens here is you
get this super position and it's x0 plus
x1 which is x0 minus s right and when
you sample a string D in the Hadamard
thesis it satisfies this equation d x0 X
or X 0 minus s equals 0 now if these two
cancelled you'd be in trouble because
then you'd get a bunch of equations with
respect to DES and if this is done mod Q
which is what we're doing here they
don't cancel there's this mod Q versus
mod 2 if you did learning parody with
noise everything would be mod 2 these
would cancel now you'd get equation with
respect to mean that you can show so
learning parody with noise was
interesting because there's an
exponential gap between the noisy
classical computation and the noisy
quantum computation you also have a
similar gap with year version of
learning with errors I'm interested in
gap in the presence of noise there for
noisy remember this is the IEM people
from John's mom and aunt Andrew cross
and Graham Smith but they require a
superposition of your training
thank you I think that could potentially
still be okay because you wouldn't get
cancellation that's the the key problem
is if these cancel and you get equations
with respect to s well I think that
would run into issues later because we
need Q to be sufficiently large right
air parameters and forget the adapter
part of it it wouldn't run into this
immediate issue but maybe later on where
the two pre images are X 0 and X 0 X or
with a fixed asset then yeah I could
look totally different but if we just
fit it into this framework right yes
okay so any more questions about the TCF
or the crypto aspects before I move on
to commitments
okay so the rest of this talk I'm gonna
focus on this primitive called classical
commitment to quantum states which I can
build from TCF pairs so I'll start by
defining what this primitive looks like
here's the ideal behavior the motive is
it's a protocol between the classical
there a fire and a quant improving the
pot improver has a single qubit
stateside in his mind and he'd like to
commit to it which he does using a tea
SIA and the commitment is just a
classical string of Y which he sends to
the river the verifier will select a
measurement basis either had a murder
standard and asked the prover for the
measurement of his committed state in
the desired basis the guarantee of this
protocol should be that when the proven
reports the measurement to the verifier
it must be the measurement of his
committed state in the basis chosen by
the verifier so this is a pretty
powerful guarantee because what it's
saying is that the prover is just
sending a classical string but this is
tying his hands so that once the verify
asked for a measurement he has committed
to a fixed quantum state he cannot
change his mind
once the verify asked for a measurement
result so it's enforcing nan at activity
on the part of the prover now to try to
emphasize why this protocol is is so
strong I'll tell you what this looks
like with multiple qubits
and now the protocol is quite similar
there are a few differences so now the
prover is committing to an end qubit
state which means that his commitment
string Y is now going to be a
concatenation of n commitment strings
because he's going to commit to each
qubit individually the next difference
is that the verifier chooses a
measurement basis either Hadamard or
standard for each of the qubits
so the verifiers basis choice can now be
one of two to the N different strings
and so what this is saying is that this
single classical string sent by the
prover serves as a commitment to an
exponentially complex quantum state so
just spending one classical string ties
the provers hands to exponentially many
different basic choices on the very he's
tried to one quantum state
okay so hopefully you understand that
this commitment protocol is quite
powerful but just to wrap this up I'll
tie this commitment protocol to
verifiability
and then I'll go back and I'll tell you
how to build the commitment protocol
using trapdoor coffee motion peers yes
Cupid that you were setting aside that
you're committing to or a classical bit
that would be classical big commitment
wouldn't work out so it seems like there
are part some of the quantum there's a
subspace here being committed to but not
all possible things if it's a commitment
why wouldn't it work out with
computational assumptions okay
so I'll link a link commitment to
verifiability and then I'll construct
the commitment protocol and then the
final step will be to describe why the
commitment protocol is secure so why it
satisfies this non-adaptive many years
to link to verification I'll try to
highlight it in two steps and then I'll
go into the details of these Tuesday's
so the first thing to note and this came
up in Henry's talk is that a quantum
state there's a served as a certificate
for the solution to a quantum
computation so Henry referred to this as
a history state the next thing to note
which also came up in Henry's talk was
that this quantum state can be verified
by measuring it so putting these two
together we can pretty much link this
commitment protocol immediately to
verification but let me go in and fill
in the details and to do that I'll look
at classical computation for a second
if we wanted to verify an efficient
classical computation one way to do that
is to convert the computation to a 3sat
formula and then verify that the 3sat
formula is satisfiable and that's pretty
easy all the verifier has to do is ask
for a satisfying assignment and verify
that the formula is satisfied now in the
classical in the quantum world we can
draw a direct analogy here 3sat
corresponds to local Hamiltonian an
n-bit variable assignment corresponds to
an end qubit quantum state and a number
of unsatisfied clauses of the formula
with respect to the assignment
corresponds to the energy of the quantum
state with respect to the Hamiltonian so
this analogy lets us come up with a
verification protocol with a quantum
verifier so what a quantum verifier can
do is verify that a local hamiltonian h
has low energy and to do this the
verifier just asks approver for a ground
state and verifies that the state has
low energy and this is quantum because
to estimate the energy the quantum
verifier has to perform Hadamard and
standard basis measurements that's all
he has to do that's the only quantum
aspect of the protocol so all he has to
do is ask for a quantum state perform
Hadamard it's in standard basis
measurements and then do some classical
post-processing on those results and
he's done okay so given this set up Oh a
classical verifier needs to do is take
the work of a quantum verifier which was
taking the state and measuring it and
force the prover to do it so the
classical verifier needs to force the
quantum proofer to non adaptively
perform the measurements and this is
exactly what the measurement protocol
does so the measurement protocol forces
the prover to commit to a quantum state
and then measure that state in the basis
desired by the bear yes it's sufficient
necessary for what for verification in
general if I'm going this route where I
want a classical verifier to get
approver to do his work for him for this
specific setup vinius but there are many
other ways you could try
are there any other questions about this
aspect because from here on out I'm not
going to talk about verification I'll
just talk about commit
and for the rest of this talk I'm not
gonna focus on the end cubic commitment
protocol I'll focus on the single cubic
commitment protocol just for simplicity
and to remind you of how it goes the
previous to a single qubit quantum state
with a classical stream using a trapdoor
clock resumption the verifier chooses a
measurement basis either had a murder
standard and the prover should be forced
to measure the committed state in the
desired basis as long as you cannot
break the trap door clock reduction so
now let's go through this step by step
and I'll show you how these are done how
these steps are done with a trapdoor
pretty much so let's say that this is
the state that the prover wants to
commit to and how he commits to it using
a TCF is by sampling a random image way
and entangling his state with the
corresponding law and that's not exactly
as I said before so he takes a single
qubit state and he appends to a uniform
superposition over the domain and then
he applies the TCF pair in superposition
and he measures that legend last
register to obtain why so the classical
commitment will just be that image way
and now he's entangled his state so that
it's entangled with a claw instead of
just
okay and then so what I've said so far
is that so far all the commitment
protocol is is the verifier sending over
a TCF pair approver untangling his state
that he wants to commit with the claw
and sending over the image wire to the
verifier now remember the goal was that
the prover should not be able to change
his state prior to measurement so once
he's committed to his state if the
verifier asked him for a measurement
result he has to measure that committed
state I'll try to give you some
intuition for why that should hold and
roughly you can imagine that if the
prover didn't have access to that second
register containing x2 or x1 then he
wouldn't really have power to change the
state okay this is this large entangled
state and he only has access to that
first qubit so he can't really change
the state much and roughly that's what's
going on here because the prover doesn't
know X 0 or next one due to the claw
free property so the prover has this
large state but since he doesn't know
what most of the state looks like he
can't really change the state once the
verifier asked for a measurement now
this is a bit too strong because what
I've said so far is that this
entanglement with a claw essentially
prevents the prover from altering his
state but I do need the prover to be
able to alter the state if the verifier
asks for a measurement so for example if
the verifier asked for a Hadamard
measurement the prover should be able to
perform a Hadamard on the state and send
the result back it turns out that the
prover can do that and the reason is
that even though the prover doesn't
fully understand his state the verifier
does so the verifier has a trapdoor and
he can use a trapdoor to extract x0 next
one now he knows something about the
prover state that the prover does not
know and he can help the prover in
performing measurements so what this
means is that if the verifier wants the
gruber to do something the verifier can
help him but if the verifier doesn't
want the prover to do something then the
prover has no power on his own because
he doesn't understand his own quantum
state so now what I'll do is I'll spend
some time on this last bullet point to
tell you how the verifier can help the
prover to perform these measurements and
then to wrap up the talk I'll go back to
the second
bullet points and show you how to prove
those two before I go into the last
bullet point are there any questions you
purify it because that's usually what I
want to do in order to remove all holes
from an argument you mean if I'm dealing
with a much larger entangled state yeah
so you have classical things and quantum
things and because they're in different
universes it makes it hard to understand
all the possible holes yeah is there a
simple way to see what you've done if I
had beautified everything so that
everything were just bonnet yet so that
is what I've done so I've taken the
whole prove your space and just written
it as a very large quantum state
okay so I'll get more into that in the
soundness protocol so what I do is that
I move everything to the end except the
measurement of Y the measurement of Y
matters and I look at the state after
the measurement of Y and everything else
is moved to me yeah so the state that
I'm analyzing is the state post
measurement of Y
so okay now I'll focus on this last
bullet point of how the verifier can
help the favorite apartment I'm gonna
focus on the Hadamard basis measurement
now the honest prover has a single qubit
quantum state and his goal is to just
apply the Hadamard to his state and
measure so he has a single qubit state
that he wants to commit to and
eventually he's gonna want to do
Hadamard measurement and report now the
problem is that once the prover commits
to his state he doesn't have that single
qubit anymore he has this much larger
quantum state and now that he has this
much larger quantum state he can't just
perform the Hadamard on it it won't make
sense so it turns out that what he can
do instead is he can take this much
larger state and convert it into
something else so he can convert it back
into a single qubit which has almost the
form of the top line which is the ideal
solution but it's off by this bit flip
so for those of you who might not
remember this X operator is just the
poly bit flip so if R is equal to one it
flips the registers and R is equal to
zero it doesn't now the point is R is
unknown to the prover so to the prover
this state doesn't look like anything
but R can be computed using the trapdoor
so the verifier does know R so what this
means that the prover can compute almost
the ideal thing up to something that the
verifier can remove now to put all this
together what this looks like is when
the prover wants to perform a hat amide
measurement the prover apply the
Hadamard transform to this entire
community the result of that is this
state so previously what I refer to as a
bit R is now this string D and with the
inner product with X 0 excellent
excellent
and now the prover can just measure this
state and it back to the verifier and
the verifier can decode the measurement
result by X owing it with this inner
product the verifier can compete that
because the verifier knows the trapdoor
so this is the protocol with the honest
proving the prover has this committed
state he measures everything in the
Hadamard basis and the verifier decodes
the final measurement result to obtain
the Hadamard measurement result of the
single qubit yeah for an honest prove
your DS uniformly random
so this is a this is a commitment
protocol so far the verifier sons over
at TCF pair the prover commits and
reports an image why then the verifier
can ask him to perform how to mark
measurement and I showed you how that's
done I didn't say anything about the
standard basis and the standard basis is
relatively straightforward compared to
the Hat of my basis that's roughly
because so first of all standard basis
measurement is easy here because you can
just measure the state and you'll either
get 0 X 0 or 1 X 1 and the reason that
it's non-adaptive is because if the
prover can alter the standard basis
distribution it essentially means he can
map X 0 to X 1 or X 1 to X now this is
the intuition is straightforward but to
make to make it entirely non adaptive
for multiple qubits I do require another
cryptographic primitive which I'm not
gonna get into in this talk for the rest
of this talk I'll just focus on the
security of a Hadamard basis so I showed
you how it was done for an honest prover
but now I need to tell you why it's true
for a cheating proven so for an
arbitrary prover how can I argue that he
has committed to a quantum state and
when he's asked for a measurement result
he reports the measurement result as
requested yes
so okay the in the standard basis what
he should report is zero with
probability of 0 squared + 1 would
probability alpha 1 4 so let's imagine
he can alter that and instead once it's
entangled he can report 0 with
probability alpha 0 prime squared + 1
would probability alpha 1 prime square
and what that means if he can take this
and map it to alpha 0 prime or alpha 1
prime that means he essentially has a
unitary which can map xeo to
so now we have to prove the security of
a hat on my basis and this is what I
refer to as a found Nisour the
commitment article so it's showing non
adaptivity on the part of the program
now this is this is probably the hardest
part of the protocol because it's quite
tricky to enforce structure for a
quantum proving so a quantum prove er
can have a very large Hobart space and
we have no idea what the prover is doing
with his face and what we need to do is
use cryptography to enforce structure on
the prover space to say that the prover
must be applying the operations we're
telling him to about so for example the
first issue that comes up is that how do
we even know that the prover has a
committed state because I keep referring
to the prover creating a quantum state
and committing to it but for all I know
the prover could be working with
classical distributions and then just
generating an image why from some
classical distribution so that's the
first hurdle and the way to get over
this is by adding an extra component to
the protocol which is called a test
round and in the test round the verifier
randomly asked approver for a pre-image
of why after the previous comments so
after the proving reports why the
verifier will sometimes just ask the
prover to report a pre-image of way now
if the prover was honest so if he
actually committed to this quantum state
this is very easy he can just measure
his state in the standard basis and
he'll obtain advantage but what if he
didn't so what if he didn't have a
committed state in mind then what this
test does is it creates structure
because what it tells us is that at some
point in time somewhere in the prover
space there was a pre-image and we know
that because the prover must have
measured some part of his space to
obtain a pre-image so what that means is
we can look at the entire approvers
space and write it down like this so
this might look complicated but all it's
saying is that at some point in time
there was some pre image in a register
held by the prover so this side just
represents the extra space of the prover
but all you should really notice here is
now we have a state which has the pre
images of why
so this is the this is the first step
and it's probably the most important
stuff because it's giving us some
structure and from here on out we can
work with the structure because now we
have defined a committed state so this
is the committed state it's a
superposition over preimages and now we
just need to argue that he's behaving
correctly on this community always has
asked approver to because you say what
you mean do you always do it or we just
do it with probability with probability
like 1/2 but then you only get this
state with probability no because then
you can make the claim that if the
prover passes perfectly so do you model
approver and you know that the previa
has some probability of passing the test
round so the first thing we say is if he
passes perfectly then I can write his
state in this form if he doesn't pass
perfectly he has some trace distance
from the perfect food
and a little worried about that because
you're trying to use a single round
logic on a multi round protocol about
entanglement between the rounds of the
protocol yeah that is an issue and the
reason first of all the commitment is in
each qubit is committed to with
independence about once you know in many
many commitments so can you vent it from
happening but he's gonna have some trace
distance from the ideal group and then
that'll impact the soundness in some way
right but that might be absolutely big
enough to allow the uber to ossify one
commitment yeah okay so what you do is
eventually like any of these statements
remember we had so what this will
eventually link to is a quantum state
for this quantum verification procedure
so anything that he does can be I can
use it to construct a quantum state
which by the same logic and criteria
that led to all the falls from foreign
key distribution where the criteria
there that's decided that the the
eavesdropper does not even get a single
bit of the key and I guess the analog
here would be the prover not being able
to achieve a single round in a mini ROM
protocol yeah but see I'm I'm not going
for a very strong guarantee I'm going
for verification right so for example
for the certified randomness generate
generation protocol the guarantees that
I'm getting here aren't strong enough
it's just a different setting so I think
that might be the case with key
distribution
so this defines a committed state and
now the next step is to actually say
what the prover is doing with the
committed state so the goal is to show
that when the prover is asked to measure
the committed state in the Hadamard
basis he does that now the most general
thing that the quantum prover could do
is instead of measuring in the Hadamard
basis you could apply an arbitrary
unitary operator to the state and then
he could measure in the half of my basis
and the reason I can assume this is
because unitary operators are reversible
so I can always assume he does whatever
he wants and then at the end he does the
correct thing so in general the prover
could apply an arbitrary unitary and
then measuring the head of my basis and
then the verify will receive that result
and then decode by this bit having to do
with the now what happens is that this
is the intuition I gave earlier the
unitary u is essentially acting blindly
because the unitary u is acting on this
state but that unitary u is chosen by
the prover who doesn't know what the
state looks like and the fact that the
unitary is acting blindly is what really
restricts the power of the unitary so
what it says is that the unitary u is
essentially it's computationally
randomized by both this initial state
and the verifier is decoding and what
this means is that the U the operator U
is so limited that the prover may as
well have committed to a different state
and then perform the measurement result
so honestly in the protocol doesn't the
bloomers start to get some information
about the X and X 0 and X 1 if you'd all
switched ecfs
each time so first of all this is only
two round three reports Y and the
verifier says give me a measurement and
that's it but you have this random thing
happening so you
there's many rounds happening so even
you utilize that randomness right you
can do it all in parallel because you
can have a very
[Music]
between those different rounds happening
in yeah that's er so the inventory
doesn't have to act on a single yes yeah
that's a good reason to be worried I'll
tell you why it's okay okay okay so oh
yes yeah so this is the way to handle it
so the technique that I'll be using is
called the Pali trill this is a
technique that is very useful in the
information theoretic setting so I'll
just briefly tell you how it's used in
the information theoretic setting and
then I'll switch back to the
computational setting and let me just
remind you what the poly operators are
in the single qubit setting the Z is a
phase operator so inserts a phase of
negative 1 and X is a bit flip operator
and the key fact that I need is that the
Palio operators form a basis so what
that means is a unitary operator acting
on a single qubit can be written as a
linear combination / single qubit poly
operators and what the Polly's twhirl
refers to is the operation of
conjugating a unitary u by a randomly
chosen poly matrix and this so this
conjugation creates a new randomized
operator and the randomized operator is
very different and it's much weaker than
the original unitary you so what the
randomized operator does is it applies
each poly operator with prop with the
probability corresponding to the
coefficient in this linear combination
so what it does is it breaks down a
general unitary into just a probability
distribution over paola operators which
is much weaker than a general unitary so
this poly twirl is very useful in the
information theoretic setting for
interactive groups because in that
setting what was often the case was that
the prover could apply a general unitary
you to a quantum state but usually his
unitary you would act on this quantum
state which had a random pally applied
to it and what that meant was that his
general unitary
may as well have been a poly operator
rather than a unitary offering so it's
really restricting the power of a
general Kwan improvement it's saying
instead of thinking that a general Kwan
improver can apply a general unitary
he's just applying a poly and that means
in that setting we just had to create
interactive proofs which could guard
against cheating poly operators rather
than general unitary operators so this
was a pretty powerful technique in the
information theoretic setting because it
really restricted the power of a quant
improver and it let us characterize the
power of the quant improver and say that
he's only acting with poly operators and
not unitary not generally in turn and
here I'll use it for something similar
but it's slightly weaker now in this
setting there is randomness present in
the state but it's not as powerful as a
poly torille because it's not
information theoretic randomness and it
doesn't constitute a full poly operator
so what happens is that the unitary you
that the prover applies to the state is
conjugated by a computationally random Z
operator so is the operator comes from
two places the first place comes from
the verifier is decoding so the verifier
decoding has to do with the cloth X 0
and X 1 so that looks computationally
random to the river ii Z operator prior
to you comes from the state which also
has X 0 and X 1 in it and so this both
of these operators randomized the
unitary
now I've told you that the provers
deviation operator is conjugated by a
computationally random how easy operator
but before that I just told you what
happens if we conjugate a unitary by a
uniformly random poly and this is weaker
because now we're just dealing with Z
operators rather than both Z and ox X
operators and what happens here is that
we can't cut down the unitary you to a
distribution over pallies but instead we
can cut it down to an operator u prime
which commutes with standard basis
measurement and this turns out to be
exactly enough for this setting because
now we can assume that any general prove
ur instead of applying an operator u an
arbitrary operator u he applies an
operator u prime which commutes with
standard basis measures this allows us
to define a new committed state which is
the original committed state but it has
this attack u prime applied to it and
now the nice thing about this state is
that I know that this state is measured
honestly because for the Hadamard basis
i know that the prover just applies his
attack and measures in the Hadamard
basis so if you look at this committed
state when the prover is asked to do a
Hadamard transform he's just applying a
Hadamard transform honestly and for the
standard basis it's consistent with the
standard basis from the previous
committed state because u prime commutes
with standard basis measure so this
defines a new committed state for which
the prover measures the state honestly
and that's satisfying the guarantee of
the commitment protocol which me says
that the prove it commits to a state and
then measures honestly random Z it just
makes you a class a random function am I
correct about that
it's not a classical quantum operations
if X operations but they also have there
are still the operators there yeah so
you still have cross terms it's not a
neat thing thank you and then the second
question is these these are not being
explicitly thrown in they're just
writing from the
TCF that would and so it seems to me
that there's something circular because
if you do have a parallel set of
protocols going on the poober could
learn something about the x0 the next
one yes that's true and so to avoid that
I do have to use independent keys for
each commitment okay so that's like
choosing driving TCS in many ways yes
yeah but that is something I don't know
how to get around I don't know how to
use this thing she's free
any more questions on the soundness
to wrap up the question that I've
addressed is whether quantum
computations can be verified classically
and this protocol relied on a primitive
called classical commitment to quantum
states the ideal functionality of this
primitive is as follows the prover
should construct a quantum state of his
choice the verify will choose a
measurement basis and the provers should
report the measurement results of his
committed state in the basis desired by
the verify the prover first commits to
his quantum state using trapped or claw
free functions and then due to the claw
free property we know that the prover is
forced to measure the committed state in
the basis desired by the earth so
putting all of this together this says
that verifiable delegation of quantum
computations is possible with a
classical machine assuming the quantum
security of learning with her
we have time for a few more questions
well even if it's large like let's say
it's n bit strings then you just start
in the state of all the zeros and do a
how to more transform on each qubit
that's rather easy herbs how easy is it
you get enough random kisi ups because
it seems to me like the number of random
PC actually might need for the protocol
should be secure might grow faster since
you'd then have to get larger piece yep
domains
does that make sense no I don't know how
hard it is to find TCF maybe that's on
the line at ACF here the one that I'm
using is just to find by learning with
everything no J's
I can use the same a but I just have to
sample a different secret s so the TCF
is defined by a and a s plus e might
start to discover well that's not we're
not so concerned about the a remember
because the a is public what hides the
claw is the secret s yeah so that's the
part that needs to change everything
because I can't there's not enough
because this the randomness is coming
from the trapdoor coffee function so
it's already present in the state and I
just don't have enough randomness for
the intro those were in previous
protocols wait a quantum verifier could
encode the state and here the state is
essentially being encoded by the
cryptography so I'm just
[Applause]